- Donner desesesesesesesesesese,
c'est un effort de guerre.
Et il est urgent.
Anastasia le fait
C'est aussi l'équivalent
un père ou un oncle.
fait la file connaît quelqu'uns.
Les combats les plus intenses
sont à moins de 30 kilomètres.
Nous som M M M Mykolaïv,
la ville d'où s'organise
la contre-offensive pour
regagner le sud de l'Ukraine.
"Le progrès est lent,
un des rares soldats qui a
accepté de pàààà la caméra.
Il est un officier sur
la deuxième ligne de défense
ne pas compromettre
l'opération militaire.
Mais cet appel au don de sang
en dit long sur les blessés
quenenenentent.
Il espère se reposer quelques
heures, quoiquaussi,
on ne dort jamais tranquille.
La ville rempart de Mykolaïv
des bombardement russes.
(fracas de verre brisé)
La dernière attaque sur Mykolaïv
remonte à il y memememe pas
24 heures. Le missile est tombé
ici, en pleine rue, a endommagé
Il y avait pas de cible précise,
en tout cas, certainement pas
"C'est pout t t t t t t t t t te
du nettoyage.
Mykolaïv n'a plus d'eau
courante. Il faut venirnsnsnsnse
pour faire la vaisselle.
Il n'y a que quelques
épiceries ouvertes. Les gens
ne t
constamment dans la peur.
"On attend qu'ils nous
distribuent des,s,s,s, dit cette
femme. On a besoin de manger
et on a besoin de médicaments.
Quatre ONG se partagent
cette seule intersection et,
au cas où les sirènes
se décle....
"On peut supporter la faim,
les pénuries d'eau,
"Les bombes, j'en peux plus!"
(déflagration)
Quelques minutes plus tard,
une série d'explosions envoie
(déflagration)
Mais c'est la terreur
quotidienne avec lenenenenenene.
En attendant que ça se calme,
Nicolaï joue sur son téléphone.
Sa mère prie.
"Oui, on a peur, on vient
se proicicicici dans
les sous-sols et les abris,
mais on se dit, en tout cas,rar:
Bien, ce sont les Ukrainiens qui
repoussent les Russes. C'est ça
qui tient la population en vie.
pour lui donner des nouvelles.
C'esououououtine quotidienne.
Et la vie reprend,
là où nous l'avons laissée.'a'ae
humanitaire, cette femme
est inconsolable.
Elle était venue au centre
de don pour chercher des bottes
pour un ami, mais on lui a dit
"Aidez-les, je vous en supplie!
Donnez-leur des mi,,,,
des munitions, ce dont ils ont
besoin pour nous défendre.
Mykola est un conscrit,
envoyé en renfort pour
tenir têteususususses.
Il n'est que de passage
ravitailler les troupes.
On lui demande comment elles
vont, il évoque les blessés.
mais on tient le coup."
Ici T
Radio-Canada, à Mykolaïv,
dans le sud de l'Ukrain